We're asked to convert
the following equation
from point-slope to
slope-intercept form.
And so this is the
equation right over here.
Let me get my little
scratch pad out here.
Let me see if I
can remember this.
It's y plus 13 is equal
to 4 times x plus 2.
So let's write that down.
We have y plus 13 is
equal to 4 times x plus 2.
So this is in point-slope form.
And just inspecting
this, I can tell you
that the slope of the line
described by this equation
is 4.
I could tell you that the
point x equals negative 2,
y equals negative
13 is on this line.
So we know the point
x equals negative 2, y
equals negative 13
is on this line.
Because when you put
something in point-slope form,
it's of the form where
this is the slope,
and this would be x
minus one of the points.
So x minus negative
2 is positive 2,
and y minus the
y-coordinate of that point,
so y minus negative
13 is positive 13.
But let's actually convert
this into slope-intercept form.
And that of course,
is a form y is
equal to mx plus b,
where m is the slope
and b is the y-intercept.
And we're going to
do this just with
some algebraic manipulation.
And you can imagine,
once we do this,
the m should still be this 4.
So let's do that.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is distribute this
4 over the x plus 2.
So this is going to be equal
to 4x plus 4 times 2 is 8.
4 times x plus 4 times
2, so it's 4x plus 8.
And we still, of course,
have our y plus 13 here.
And now we're pretty
close to getting it
into slope-intercept form.
We just have to subtract
13 from both sides.
And I'm going to
have it of the form y
is equal to something
times x plus something.
So let's do that.
Let's subtract 13
from both sides.
And we will get on the
left-hand side just y.
And on the right-hand side,
we are going to have 4x.
And then 8 minus
13 is negative 5.
So we get y equals 4x minus 5.
And let's just type that in and
see if we got the right result.
So y is equal to 4x minus 5.
So y is equal to 4 times x, and
they just have a positive here.
So I would write
plus negative 5,
the same thing as 4x minus 5.
So let's check our answer,
and we got it right.